Briefing's Donald Trump ran on having the
most transparent administration in history.
Part of transparency is having press briefings.
Donald Trump's last press secretary, Stephanie
Gresham, had zero.
That's not a typo.
Zero press briefings.
Not a single press briefing during her tenure.
The point of the press secretary is to bridge
the gap between what Trump is thinking and
doing and planning and the press.
And Stephanie Grisham held zero press briefings.
She was recently replaced by Kaley McEnany
or McKenney.
Take your pick.
She had her first press briefing on Friday.
We covered it live as it was happening.
And it was a house of horrors.
I will spare you a lot of the absolutely meaningless
answers she gave, which had no substance.
But I want to focus on one thing.
She was asked during the press briefing, will
you pledge never to lie to us?
Never to lie to the press?
And she said, yes, I will never lie to you.
And then she lied her way through the entire
press briefing.
Let's start with that question coming from
the press corps.
Will you lie to us?
And she looked absolutely days, the entire
press conference.
One of the strangest ones I've seen.
But here is her answer about lying.
Very exists in more than 100 days, as the
press secretary said, there is better sense
of what your plan is.
Are you planning to do these daily basis at
this point?
And also, we pledge never to lie to us.
I will never lie.
Here you have my word on that.
As to the timing of the briefings on we do
plan to do them.
I pledge not to lie to you.
And then she spends the entire press briefing
lying.
Let's take a brief tour of the lies.
She claimed, for example, that the Mueller
report was a total exoneration of Donald Trump
and a lot of your papers.
I've seen a whole lot of scant information
about Michael Flynn when there is a whole
lot of speculation about Russia, Russia, Russia,
culminating in 40 million dollars of taxpayer
money being lost and the complete and total
exoneration of President Trump.
Thank you guys so much.
This is an acute provable lie.
Robert Mueller actually said if we could have
exonerated Donald Trump on obstruction of
justice, we would have said it.
So it is a direct lie that the Mueller report
was an exoneration of Trump McCain.
And he also said that the Mueller investigation
cost 40 million.
That's a popular Trump's talking point.
Even Trump has said it.
The truth is the costs of the investigation
were 32 million, but it recovered, according
to one report.
Forty two million.
It recovered according to another report.
Forty six million.
So the Mueller report recovered more money
than it cost.
She also said not a single ventilate.
Not a single American has died for lack of
a ventilator.
Trump has been saying that it's really hard
to know if that's true for sure.
But we have reporting that multiple people
had to be placed on one ventilator, which
you're not supposed to do.
We know that a terminally ill person had to
be removed from a ventilator to put someone
with Corona virus on it.
We know that some hospitals did have rationing
decisions to make about ventilators.
So we certainly can't say for sure that no
one died due to a lack of ventilators.
Big lie on Michael Flynn.
Donald Trump's convicted former national security
adviser, Kailey McEnany, said that there was
a handwritten FBI note that said we need to
get Flynn to lie.
And they are alleging that this means that
there was a sort of perjury trap setup.
All this is, is interrogators planning an
interrogation.
Interrogators already knew Flynn had lied
and they were trying to get the lies on the
record.
That's all it is.
They are trying to make it out to be some
smoking gun.
And it's not.
Now, last thing on this, what the White House
press corps should have asked Kelly.
And they didn't ask her about this, is that
she went on TV in February and she said President
Trump isn't like Obama.
President Trump will never let the Corona
virus come to the United States.
Here are her words.
Don't take my word for it.
Absolutely.
This president will always put America first.
He will always protect American citizens.
We will not see diseases like the Corona virus
come here.
We will not see terrorism come here.
Isn't that refreshing when contrasting it
with the awful presidency of President Obama?
Candy McEnany, thank you so much.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
That's what Kaley McEnany should be asked
about.
And I hope she will be Caylee.
You told us in February that Trump would never
allow Corona virus to come here.
We now have 1.2 million cases and our death
rate is the 14th highest in the world.
Can you admit you were wrong about Donald
Trump?
That's the question that should be asked.
It wasn't.
Hopefully we will see it asked
in
the future.